で まあ経典やら仏教では一般的にそれ言ってるんですけど
そのメカニズムは説明してないんです
その代わりに言うのは
やっぱり例えば人が清らかな心でいると
悪いカルマには結果出すことはできないと
例えば人が貧しく生まれたんだけど
それを上うそついたりするともっと貧しくなる
貧しく生まれたんだけど
正直者で働き者で すごい謙虚的で
だったら誰か助けてあげちゃうんですね
この今世の心の働きが問題ないんだから
で あの人は大変働き者で
正直者で働いたっても
お金もなかなか入るほうもないし
まあいいんじゃないか
助けてあげましょうという気持ちに人々がなる
そこで人々がその人を助けてあげる
その場合は その人の死後が働いて助けてくれる
死後に死後現れたのは
その人の今世の心の回転の本当なんですね
ですから やっぱり今世の生き方も大変大事ということは
我々具体的には言うんですね
倫理的な立場で 過去の業に悩むんじゃなくて
過去の業はもう決まったもんだから放っておきましょうと
生まれてから我々はどのように生きているかと
そういうことによって自分の人生を支持してくれるか
妨害してくれるかっていうこともありますと
それぐらいしかないんですね
説明してない 例えば慈悲の気持ちある人が病気になったと
病院に行ってもなんかみんな随分仲良くしてくれるんです
薬も早く効く お医者さんもその人はもう見たくてしょうがないとかね
ちょっと言ってちょっと話しましょうとかね
あの患者さんが面白いと
通り 通る時でもその部屋をね
どう元気ですかと一言葉でもかけるとかね
それはその人は慈悲の心を持ってるんだから
悪い業が働いて病人病院に行ったかもしれませんだけど
心が優しいんだから やっぱりみんなに親切にしてくれるということはあるんですね
そこで病気もすぐ発見できるとかね
そういう方の働きなんですけどね
そこはね 人間のやっぱり生き方は自分で今世で決められるという立場でしょう
だから運命論じゃないんだから
いくら業のこと仏教で言っても運命論じゃないし
運命だ定めだどうしようもないという立場は絶対言ってないんですね
それだけ邪見だと それは
ですから 仏教で徹底的に言うのは努力しなさい
頑張りなさいと それは否定するのは全部非道徳的だと言ってるんですね
すごい恐ろしい その立場ではきついんです
人の努力否定 わずかでも否定するんだったら
もう道徳に反すると そういう立場を持ってるんですね
ですから 人はどんな運命を持って生まれても
まあいい方向に頑張りなさい
努力はそれなりに結果が出してくれるんだということを言ってるんです
だから努力すればカルマが変わるんですね
そこで正しい方向へ常に死ぬ瞬間までも努力してほしいという立場に
そういうのは一応説明するためにこんなことを言っている可能性もあります
どういうことか 例えば幸福に生まれる人々を見ると
二種類いるでしょう 一種類の幸福な人々が幸福に生まれたんだからといって
それで威張らないで もう大変素晴らしい生き方をする
世の中のために生きる
そういう人々はいるでしょう
その人々は大変もう幸福から幸福へ行ってしまうちゃう
死んでからでも その人々の名前はみんな覚えておいて尊敬する
インドの例なんですけど
例えばガンジーさんがいるんです
いたんですね ガンジーさんが大変恵まれてる家で生まれた人なんですね
まあ召使やらいくら何でもあっても
すごい贅沢に生きることはできたんです
王様みたいな感じで それで彼が見たのは自分のすごい豊かな姿と自分が生まれていた国を見たら
これ大変だと 私はこんなに恵まれて
他の人々はもうご飯も食べられないんだと
あ これはいけませんと思って
もう外へ出たでしょうし
外へ出てもう行動を始めて
まあ一生懸命自分の財産を絞ったりして
で 最後に服も着なかったでしょう
裸にはいなかったわけないんだけど
たった 1枚だけ腰に巻いてるだけ
自分だったらすごい贅沢に洋服であろうと弁護士さんでしたから
アフリカで ですから 金儲けようと思ったら
いくらでも金儲かる ものすごい頭良かったし
できたのに 自分がちょっと 1枚だけ腰に巻いて
それでイギリスに行くんです
寒いのに だから誰でも当時は船でしたけど
外国なんか行く場合はやっぱりイギリス式なりにちゃんと服を着てもう行きますからね
イギリスっていうのはいろいろ厳しいんだからね
そういうくだらないことにはね
ネクタイついてるかないかとかね
もうそうでないと もう例えば国会なんかに入る場合は
ちゃんとネクタイがないと入れませんし
裁判に行く時でもちゃんと服を着まってないともう入れてくれないしね
で それをね この人はもうきちんと頑固と王様に会おうがもう関係ない
その自分のそれは自分のみんなのためにやってる行動だから
すごい生き方なんですね
ですから とにかく非暴力主義でインドに独立を独立にしたんですね
誰とも喧嘩しないで だからいまだに神様だとみんな拝んでるんです
で そういう風な人々もいるし
それでお金持って お金で遊びたい放題遊んで
人のことをバカにして生きてる人々もいるし
その人々はもうどう見たっても不幸になって死んでしまっちゃうし
で 昨日テレビで見てたんだけど
このなんとかイタリアどこかな
このベニス？なんかこの仮面かぶって遊ぶなんとかというカーニバル祭りやってる番組あったんだけど
昔なんか誰かがね もう昔この男も女も仮面かぶって遊びたい放題遊ぶんだとかね
で そこを歴史を辿ってみたら
その人々は幸福になったけど
幸福になったわけで すごい金があったんだけど
遊んで遊んでもいろいろ不幸になった例なんです
結局は まあそのちょっと思い出せませんだけど
ですから 密集いるんですね
幸福な人々の間でも 自分にお金あるんだからって威張って高慢で
人のことはもう気にしない
勉強もしない 悪いことをだけしたりしてね
親からお金くれるんだったら
もう遊ぶことしかしないとかね
その人々は自分も不幸
周りも不幸にしてしまっちゃうし
だからはっきり言うならば
もういてほしくない人間になっちゃうんですね
この世の中で それで同じく不幸な人々は種類見られるでしょう
不幸で生まれるんだけど
頑張り屋で謙虚で もうかさぶらいでもなんとかしてもうもう養おうとかね
一生懸命やってる人々もいて
その人々もそれなりに
まあお金なくたっても愛情だけでもあって死ぬでしょう
そういう時はもういっぱい愛情に包まれて死ぬことはできるし
誰もそういう人々に悪いことをしようとはしないし
そこでまた不幸に生まれただけではなくて
それで腹が立って泥棒するわ
嘘をつくわ 人を騙すわ
スリやるわ いろんなことやってる人々はもう不幸から次に不幸へ行ってしまっちゃうんですね
そういう論理だから 人はお釈迦様
他の教で言ってましたからね
明るく光から光へ行く人々
光から闇へ行く人々 闇から光へ行く人々
闇から闇へ行く人々というのは種類しているんですね
それ今説明してたものなんですね
光から光へ生まれる行くっていうのは
すごい幸福に生まれて
健康的で生まれて それからもいいことばっかりして
死後ももっと明るいところで幸福なところに行くんだと
そのシステムで闇から闇へ行く人々もいるんだと
闇から光へ行く人々もいるんだと
ですから そちらのポイントは自分の過去の業に依存するなってことなんです
気にするな どんな生まれかってことだと思います
私は生まれたからの業が悪いんだからしょうがないと
そんなことは仏教では認めないんです
なぜならば あんた知ってますかと
どんな業で生まれたんですか？知らないでしょうね
過去で私は何をやったんだから
今世でこの人間に生まれたかと
知らないでしょうね ですから
自分の運命は業のせいにするのは良くないんです
業論は喋ってはいるんだけど
自分の運命 業のせいにするな
きちんと理性を持って
合理的に堂々と前向いて行動しなさい
そうすると人生は運命は変わるんだと
その立場はもうはっきりしているんです
ですから 決して業論は運命論ではないんですね
運命論ではないということははっきりと仏様は説明しているんです
一切は業によりますよという言葉は邪見であって
邪教だと 人間の幸福すべてが業のせいだというのは邪見なんです
すごい邪見なんです 邪見たくさんありますけど
中で そういうことで人は頑張るべきですよ
いわゆる希望を失わないようにしているんですね
で なんとかすればいいじゃないかと
たとえ障害を持って生まれても
これは過去の業だからしょうがないと
その人は自分を捨ててはいけないんです
自分を捨てるんじゃなくて
こんな体で生まれたんだけど
私に何ができるかと考えればいいんです
目がなくて生まれてもそれは構いません
しょうがないんです その人の過去の業だから
それでその人は目がない自分に何ができるかと
見て行動すればそれなりにうまくいくんです
だから目がなくたっても耳がいい人々はいるでしょ
なんかアメリカにいるでしょ
なんか歌ってる人が 何でしたっけ？あの人は名前は
黒人の  Sting で すごいでしょうに
まだ歌もすごいね 綺麗な
汚い歌ではないし いつも
だから彼に何が別に不自由ですかね
何の不自由もないでしょうし
だからまあ彼はそれなりに業がいいかもしれませんからね
それなりに声を持って生まれたかもしれませんだけど
で そんな声なくたってなんかできることはあるんですからね
仏教の教えはそういう教えなんですけど
なかなかそういうこの障害者を助ける施設とか
なかなか仏教の人は作ってないんですね
あれはなんかおかしいんですね
キリスト教の教えから見ればあれ不可能なんです
すべて神様が決めるんだから
説明できないはずなんですね
なんでこの人は目が見えなく生まれたんですかと
耳が聞こえないように生まれたんですかとかね
かわいそうでしょうし
一回しかない人生だから
それなのにキリスト教の人々はその人々みんな集めて一生懸命あの
なんとかしようとはしているんですね
それはできるのは本当のことを言うと仏教の世界なんです
仏教の世界なら確実にできるはずなんです
なぜならば 基調とした論理はできているんだから
たとえ耳が聞こえなくたって
お前怠けるんじゃないよと
人を恨むんじゃないんですよと
明るい心でも頑張りなさいと
助けてあげますから というような
そういう福祉的な行動をするならば
これは何と何のも問題なくできるなのが仏教の人々なんですが
全然やってないんですね
まあ全然というわけじゃないんだけど
ほとんどやってない 僕もやっぱりそういうのはすごく疑問に思うことなんですけどね
今は仏教の人々はもうお金も財産もなくて貧しいんですけどね
やっぱりそういうことを
やった方が良かったんじゃないかなと
まあ一つはなぜそういう組織ができてないかというと
問題なかったんですね
社会的には 昔は 問題にしなかったんです
例えば家族に障害者が生まれたら
母親は全然困らなかったんです
全然認めるんですね 何のことはなく
この子はこういう状態ですよ
だからもう不幸な人とか
まるっきりなく 一生懸命育てて面倒見てあげる
ですから 社会問題にならない
施設作る必要なくなっちゃう
兄弟も親戚も あの家は
あの人は何であんな不幸な人が生まれたんですか？とかね
そういう差別感がなかったんですね
だから 障害持ってる母親は何のことなく堂々と行動するし
自分がどこか出かけたい場合は
もう親戚誰かいるんだったら何のことも子供預かっちゃうし
じゃあこの子供の面倒を私は出かけますからと
その人々もそれなりにもう面倒見るんですね
まあ今も自分の国でも大体もう全く障害を持ってる人の面倒見るっていうことは
もう何のことなくまあやるんですね
家族レベルで だからバスに乗ろうと思ったら
ちょっと障害持ってる人が
日本みたいに車椅子をちゃんと入れるように
自動的な機械作る必要ないんです
向こうはそんなバスあるわけでもないし
すごい満員ばっかりですけど
満員バスでも何か障害持ってる人が乗ろうとしちゃうと
みんな 喧嘩してバスに乗るんです
乗るんだけど そういう人が待ってても乗れないでしょうに
みんなみんなに怒って
あんたが何やってるの？ちょっと道を開けなさいと
で 誰かがその人を囲んで中に入れるんです
入れてちゃんと座らせてあげるんです
いくら満員バスでひばっても
それはあんまり気にしない
恵みがない人だったら
もう何のことなく誰かがもう連れて行っちゃう
ですから ごく一般的なことになってるんだから
もしかすると特別に福祉運動とかにはならなかったか
社会問題にならなかったかもしれない
老人問題とかね ならなかったし
そこで老人ホームというのは
最近まで自分の国ではあれは大恥だと思っていたんです
老人ホームできちゃったら
それこそ大恥ですよ なんということですか
だからよく普通の不幸な人でないと老人ホームに行かないんです
ですから 老人ホームありますけど
仏教の人々やってる老人ホームありますけど
やっぱりそれはもうもうもうものすごい気に入られてるような
選ばれてるような不幸な人々なんですね
いわゆる体に問題あるわけじゃなくて
まあそれなりにもう結婚してなかったとかね
あるいはもう何の身寄りもなくて
あっちこっちもう若い子とあっちこっち生活していて
それで自分の家もないし
いるところもないし もう行くとこなくても最後に老人ホームとか
にはなるんだけど 普通だったらもう親の面前で子供いるということはもう当たり前で
いわゆる老人を尊敬することこそがもう大変ありがたと感じるんですね
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんなんかいると
みんな大変喜んで喜んで
いることはすごく喜ぶんです
だからおばあちゃんおじいちゃんになっちゃったらね
大体お寺に行くしか何もやりませんだけどね
だから孫たちやら息子にしたっても
仕事はあってももう向こうにも見えますから
向こうはこの朝早く向こうも仕事に出かけなくちゃいけないし
もう仕事に行くことも大変戦いだから
もしその前日はこの自分の母親がお寺に行きたいと思ったならば
ちゃんと連れてくるんです
ちゃんと連れてきて お寺に入れて
じゃあ仕事に行くと それで自分ができない場合は
孫が来てちゃんと面倒は見る
ですから 別におばあちゃんたちにも別に要らないんですね
老人ホームなんか 去年かな
去年か今年かな 向こうのそういう私とすごい親しくしていたおばあちゃんが病気になって
結構大変になってね よく連絡あってね
私が特別に行ってお見舞いに行った方がいいんだと
いつもあなたのことを言ってるんだと
行ったら喜ぶだろう 聞いたとたん向こうも忙しいんだけど
まあお寺の側のうちなんでしたけども
聞いたことはなんとなく行きたくなっちゃうんですね
それで ああそうですか
で 僕も全部他の仕事をやめちゃって
おばあちゃんにお見舞いに行ったんです
うちに行ったら もう他の息子が来て
自分のお嫁さんですか
もうそっち連れて行ってくださいと
そう言ってそこに連れて行かれて
他の遠いところです そこでもうめんどくさくないと面倒見られるんだと
言って 私はその場所は知らない
まだ遠いし そこで道を聞いて聞いて聞いて
もう 8回ぐらい聞いたんで
またもうそんなね 田舎だからね
街灯あるわけでもなんでもないし
ここら辺に行って右に曲がればいいって言ったって藪しか見えないし
右に曲がれるかな かなり苦労して
もう一応行ったんだけどね
やっぱり行ったらすごい自分に対しての気持ちがいいもんなんですね
この嫁さんにしたっても
まあ文句言ってるんだけど
その文句は悪い文句じゃなくて
このおばあちゃん全然言うことを聞いてくれないんだと
自分がもうただベッドに寝ていればいいのに
あっちこっち歩いたりしているんだと
でもやっぱり優しく まあおばあちゃんもその悪口を何のことなく
まあニコニコと笑いながらね
だからこの寝たきりみたいな状態でした
そんなそんな当時は治りましたけど
でもやっぱり自分が年上で
家のみんなのリーダーと精神的なリーダーというのがずっといるんですね
ですから そういうなんとなく
このお互いに愛情の雰囲気っていうのは
仏教はなんとなく作るんだから
親戚でない人々も 誰かそういう風な人が病気になったら
もうお見舞いに行く だからほとんど家にいるんです
家にいるんだから 年取った人は病気になったっても病院なんかに行きたくない
どうせ死ぬっていうことは知ってるし
みんなに迷惑だから みんな来てなんとかしゃべって
なんとか遊んでもう帰りますから
やっぱりみんなのことを考えて
まあ病院はいいですよと言って静かに死を迎えちゃうんですね
だから本当は仏教の世界ではね
そういう施設なんかはまあいらない
いらない状態ですかね
やっぱり でも社会変わるとやった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
今はもう全部変わってるんだからね
論理的には仏教の人々にはね
そういう風に人を助けることは何のことなくできるんです
悪い障害で生まれても
その人は努力すればよろしいし
全く努力できないような子の完全障害に生まれたっても
その人の面倒は死ぬまで見てあげることだと
というふうなことですけどね
まあ大体こんなことで
まあ仏教ではこの人が努力するべきで
努力しなきゃよくないんですね
努力しなきゃ妨害業はどんどん次から次へとついてくる
努力しちゃうと 支持業がいろんな支持業がついてくるということです
それはそれで まあアホセカンマの説明に全部話が崩れてしまったんだけどね
アホセカンマっていうのはとにかく結果を出せなくなった
出せる機会は失った それでカンマがもうアホセと終わったと
消えた アホセっていうのはこの消えたという意味なんですね
本当はこの be動詞の過去形
過去形ですけど  was という意味はもう今はないという意味なんです
ですから消えたという意味なんですね
消えるから 結果出せないで消えるカンマ
だからこのこちらのなんかこれきゅうと読むんですか？きゅうごう
まあとにかくアホセという言葉の意味は消えたという意味なんですね
業が消えました 言いたがっているのはそこら辺ではなくて
例えばこのまあ話完全に戻ります
我々にはこの限りないカルマが溜まっている
それからずっと溜まり続けて味わうカルマはほんのわずか
だからいくら味わっても消えません
それで人がもし悟ったとしても
たとえ預流果に悟ったとしよう
預流果のレベルに悟ったならば
いくらインナテンションでだっても七回に限る
その七回も決して地獄には落ちません
天界か人間かどちらかなんです
そこでもすごい幸福には生まれる
だからその人には七回しか業は結果出せませんし
あの巨大な業はどうなったかというと
全部無効になる もう機能しない
何もできなくなる それでカルマはもうものすごく消える
お釈迦様はたとえでこう言うんです
ある日 この土一つ 大地からすねで取って
自分のすねで取って比丘たちに聞くんです
あなた方 私のすねの上にあるこの土とこの大地の土
どちらの方が多いんですか？だからまあこれ比べられないでしょうに
お釈迦様のすねちょっとね
土から土取っただけだから
といったら それは比べようにならないんだと
大地の方が土が多いんだと
だからこう言うんです
人が預流果に悟ったならば
彼に残っている苦しみは
このすねの上に残っているぐらいのものだと
彼が決した苦しみが大地の土のようなものだと
そのたとえでものすごい明快なんです
どれぐらいの業が結果出せなくなって無効になったかと
残っているのは土の上に残っている分だけです
いや なくてすねの上に残っている分だけです
これナカツカスッタという名前の経典でも結構有名です
だから預流果になったら
もう大地の土の量ぐらいの業がアホ・スッカムになっちゃうんです
ほんのちょっとわずか残りますけど
それはすねの上に乗っている土ぐらいのもうわずかな量
それはもう七回でも消えてしまう
じゃあもし四番目に悟ったならば
四段階に 日本の柔道みたいにいろいろ段階
十段とかはないんですけどね
まあ段階 まあ一応段階ですけど
段階になったならば もう完全に悟ってるでしょ
全部業がアホ・スッカムになっちゃう
もう生まれ変われません
でもほんのわずか残っている
残っているのはこの体
体が作った業があるんだから
そこはもう終わりまで維持しちゃいますね
その人にも四事業と五蓋業は働くんです
阿羅漢になっても だから死ぬまでは四事業
五蓋業は働くみたい ですから人の運命っていうのは波ですよ
結局は ずっと一本一本みたいに直接一本につながるということはない
それでも波 それは阿羅漢になっても同じこと
お釈迦様にもご飯がなかった時はあったんです
お釈迦様が行ったこのいい業の方はね
量がどれほどかというと
それでも一回は三ヶ月間ももうこの信者さんが食事作ってくれなかったんです
この泊まってくださいとね
ある人が頼んで で そこでお釈迦様は行に入ったんです
行に一旦入ったら 三ヶ月間もどこにも行かない
こちらで行に入ってくださいとお願いして
その人うちに帰って自分の仕事ばっかりしていたんです
そこで食事も何もない
でもやっぱりその時でもお釈迦様のとこで
何も食べ物なくなったわけじゃなくて
もうなんか突然そこら辺に馬を馬を売りに来た商人たちが
商人のグループが来て
馬たくさん連れてくるんだから
で そこでもうたくさん食料ですか
馬のための食料たくさんあったんです
だから売る馬だから ものすごい高価なこの特別な穀物あって
これは人間にはちょっと硬いんですけどね
そういうのが大量にありましたから
それはほんのちょっとちょっとみんなに分けてあげたみたいです
ですから 三ヶ月間お釈迦様は
まあそれはアーナンダ尊者がね
まあ粉にして あの茹でて
あの なんていうの 一つ玉のようにね
作って 一つだけ召し上がっていたんだと
他のお坊さんたちは それは全部このお湯に溶かしちゃってね
飲んでいたんだと 三ヶ月間
だからそういうこともありましたから
それもやっぱり まあ妨害業ですね
汚せたのはお釈迦様への一つの妨害業だと
守ってきたんです で いくつかありますね
お釈迦様にも頭痛があったんです
たまたま出て まあこれ治療で治るんだったら
もう最高なお医者さんがついていたんだからね
で これ治らないんですね
で それはあんまり気にしなかったんだけどね
ですから それも一つで
この背中が腰が痛くなる
それも経典でよく出てくることですね
ですごく腰が痛くて 体がすごく疲れる
で おそらくは結構痛かっただろうと思います
お釈迦様はいつでももう
もうすごい忍耐で もう痛みっていうのはね
もう文句言ったりはしませんでしたから
まあちょっとちょっとだけ漏れてるんですね
お釈迦様の人間らしい姿はね
お坊さんたちがあまりにも尊いんだから
もうものすごい神様のように接していますけど
やっぱり歴史的な人物でしたから
漏れてるんですよ 本当の姿はね
そこの辺で腰が痛くて
だからこれかなり痛かっただろうと思います
だから説法は途中でやめる
説法さえ途中でやめるぐらい腰が痛い
で 横になるんです そこで漏れるところは
これでサーリプッタ尊者はちゃんとベテンタッチする
ですからもう説法にはもう何も問題ない
一旦お釈迦様 喋ろうと思ったことを何ですけど
知ってるのはサーリプッタ尊者だけ
すごい智慧があったんだから
そこでお釈迦様にとってはこれすごいありがたい存在なんですね
自分の体が病気だから
だから途中で中止したくなっても構いません
それはすごい元気でしたです
だから右腕だと言ってるでしょうに
だからいつでもそばにいて欲しかったんですね
なぜかというと 自分の体調のことはちょっと信頼できない
耐久し続けるかわからない
で 崩れると サーリプッタ尊者は何のことなく
もうその日でずっと説法終わりまでする
その間お釈迦様はやっぱり横になっている
だからそういうふうに体の調子がね
良くなかったっていうことは
お釈迦様にもあったことなんです
それも妨害業だと後で注釈書では書いて
なぜ偉大なる釈尊にそんなことがあったかという
それは業害業だ そこでお腹の調子もあまり良くなかったんですね
結構苦労して教えた教えなんです
いかにこれ残酷に壊そうとしているかというとね
ご飯も食べ物もほとんどないし
毎日歩いていかなきゃいけないし
で いろんな人の食べ物を食べたりしてね
お腹を壊すし で 三ヶ月間も下痢で
それまだ赤痢でしょうし
ずっともうどこにも行けなくなっちゃって
寝たきりになってたんです
それでもやっぱりそばに来る人々にそれなりに説法する
ですから この業害業っていうのは
まあやっぱり死ぬまでついてくるものというふうに
仏教では一般的に考えている
たとえ阿羅漢になっても
そこで今の人間なんですかね
瞑想してなんか体病気治らないんですか？と聞くんだからね
本当に怒るべきなんですけど
どれほど世の中腐ってるかということなんです
なんとか修行したところでガン治ったとかね
あんまりなんですね この欲望というのは
どれほどレベル低くて品がないということでしょう
そこでもう病気なんか治りませんよと言っちゃったら
その宗教は信じませんだから
宗教というのは結局このあのヒーラー
ヒーリング作業宗教だと思ってたら
それはもう他の人々やる仕事でしょうに
体治すことはね 今 整形何師ですか
体の調子を治す人 うん
整形やってる人やら針やってる人やら
普通の治療やってる人やらいくらでもいるでしょうに
体治してあげればその人々に見ればいいし
そこで尊い瞑想をそれに使おうとかね
病気になるとかなるんです
年取るほど私来るんです
そんなものはどうでもいいことで
体のことで だからお釈迦様はそれを身をもって教えていったのにね
まあ仏教で治せる障害はいろいろありますけどね
それは別に別な法則なんですけどね
で まあそれはちゃんと仏教ではね
もう治しますし ほとんどのこの人間の病気の中で
この心から生まれる病気
我々の病気の九十パーセントぐらい心で作れる病気だから
そこら辺はもう結構治るんです
体の自然的に出ている病気は治らない
例えば年取ってくると消化はもうどんどん悪くなるでしょう
そんなものはもういくら必死になって瞑想したって治らないので諦めた方がいい
シワが出て体がどんどん曲がっちゃうんだと
それは体のカルシウムなんか逃げちゃいますからね
吸収できなくなったからね
そこまでは治りません
あるおばあちゃん 僕が国に行くと
もうお花がそちらにくるんだよ
僕は来てほしくないんだけどね
百歳以上だと思います
そのおばあちゃんの子供たちもやっぱりかなり年の人々で
結構子供がいるんです
十二人二十人いるだろうと思いますけどね
でもものすごいこの心臓が悪いんです
医者によると歩いてもいけないぐらい
血圧もあるし その上に
で やっぱり私が来たなと思ったら歩いてくるんですよ
遠くから 寺に来ると途中で何回も倒れるんです
私ももう体がもうなんか火が燃えちゃうんですね
聞くと 何やってるんです
で あれ見たんですね ちょっと階段みたいなあって
そこを登れないんですね
歩いて暑いのに歩いて歩いてきて
それまた子供たちに 孫たちに怒られるんだから
誰にも言わないで出たぞ
で 誰もない時見たらもう誰にもね
もう その日はその時私がいなかったならばもっとひどいでしょうし
次の日も来なくちゃいけないんだから
だから徳が高いんだから
来るときはだいたい私はまあいましたけど
やっぱりそういう人で一度もなんかあのお経でもあげて祝福してね
自分のこの病気の状態をね
何とかしてくださいませんか？一度も頼んだことはないんです
逆に言うのは もうこの子供たちはもう全くもう見張っていて
とんでもないんだと お寺に行きたいんだけど
もうちゃんと来てね 修行でもしたいんだけど
あの連中を見張ってる
自分の病気のことは全然気にしてない
そこでもう聞いたんで
知ってるかいないか知りたくて
自分の体の状態をね それちゃんと知ってるんです
お医者さんから明確に説明してもらって
心臓はどういう状態かとか
それ全部知ってる ですから
やっぱり素晴らしいと思ったのは甘えないということなんですね
もう仏教のおかげで あの
なんとか体が直してほしいとか
そこら辺はすごい優れているんです
尊い人々なんです だから皆さん見たっても
そのおばちゃん見たっても
その見えないかもしれません
形では もうボロボロのおばあちゃん
今まだいるかどうかわかりませんだけどね
だから僕らにしたっても感動するような性格を持ってるんです
私たちから見てもすごい尊い方ではないかと思えるぐらい
もう だから私に礼をしようと思っても
頭下げるともう倒れちゃうんです
向こうは怒っていいですよ
ばあちゃんももう座ってください
って聞かないんですね
それで 別に私は説法することじゃなくて
なんかちょっとまあなんか冗談言ったりとかね
もう日常のことしか喋りませんし
やっぱりそれでもやっぱりそういうこの人々はまあどこかでちゃんと
まあお釈迦様のメッセージをね
ちゃんと体で持ってるんです
だから現代社会とは随分違う
ガン治ってほしいとかね
自分の無力治ってほしいとかね
情けないんです そんなものに宗教に行くな
病院があるのはそのためでしょうし
心を直すためにあるものであって
お釈迦様もお医者さんですけど
それは心を直すお医者さん
お医者さんなんです ですから
お釈迦様も自分の体の調子なんかは悪くたって全く平気で
そんなことには別にめげないで
みんなのために説法し続けたんです
歩き続けたんですね お釈迦様さえ 三ヶ月間も寝たきり状態にいたのに
お釈迦様ほどの徳というのは人間に作ることはまるっきり不可能であると
ですから そこら辺は理解して
正しく仏教を理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
日本にいるある人なんですけどね
手術するようになって
怖くて 私に電話して言ったのは怖い
僕は別にいいんじゃないんですかと
別に怖い怖いと言ったって
お医者さんがそれなりにやるでしょうと
僕は言わなかったんですね
もう三宝守ってあげますからとか
お祈りしてあげますから
そのことは言わなかったことはすごく気に入ったんです
余計なことを言わなかったんだと
他の宗教との関係があった一方で
他の宗教からはもういちいちうるさいんだそうです
病気治してあげます お祈りしてあげます
私に電話して 僕は全然そんなことお医者さんに診てもらったら
結局苦労でしょうと 体切るのは
ということは言ったんですね
そこでやっぱりやっぱり道はそういう道だ
で 本人がそこでは自分が死ぬのはこんなに怖いんだからね
自分が今までどれほど人
生命を殺してきたんですかと
これっきりでもうやめますと
肉やら魚やら食べるのは
やっぱり食べる食べるものは殺されてるんだから
自分今味わっているこの恐怖感
その動物たちは味わってきたんだから
ということで 僕はどうそうご自由にと
それに別に素晴らしいと言わなかったんです
どうせそれもご自由に
でもそのそういうふうに私に言われることできたのは
それはやっぱり仏教のことをいくらか知っていたんだからな
その方が もし一般の人にそんなこと言われたら
この坊主ほど失礼な もう残酷な人がいないと思うでしょう
仕込むぐらいすれば罰が当たらないでしょうとか
思うと思いますよ あるいは私はこれから肉魚をやめますと思ったら褒めてあげるのは常識ではないか
常識じゃない それは非常識な
だから僕らの常識はそうですよ
ご自由に そういう僕とちょっと喋ったことで
やっぱりこの人は本物を教えているんだと
その人はそれで理解したんです
そういうことで 仏教の世界っていうのは
やっぱり本当の本当の宗教の世界
そういう世界なんです
聖書に出てくるようなイエス様が人の病気治したと
あれ時代錯誤なんですね
自分も否定しているんです
なんで神に病気治すことできるんですかね
まず もしできるならば
神だからできるそうと言いたいがっているでしょう
だったらなんで人間病気ですかね
誰か一人二人治しただけで
なんでその人を信じる必要あるんですかね
一人一人を治したかもしれませんだけど
事実かもしれませんだけど
治してない数 生まれる時死ぬ子供たち
生まれて七歳で死ぬ子供たち
どれぐらいいるんですかね
若い時死ぬ人々 偶然がんになったり
白血病になったりとかいろいろあったりして
その連中を見て身に染みているでしょう
その時思うのは やっぱりそれは神様に早く戻ってもらって
それだったら昔聖書に出てる連中も早く早く戻ってもらった方が良かったのに
だからああいうのはもう本当に無意味なんですね
病気治したんだと そこでいまだにその間違ってることで頑張ってるんです
病気治してあげるんだとかね
奇跡起こるんだとか どこら辺の湖
湖じゃなくてなんて湧き水があって
その湧き水に神様が力入れちゃって
そこを飲んだら癌が治るんだとかね
なぜある一か所の湧き水だけそうするんですかね
そこら辺にある井戸は全部もう水はね
もうそういう風に病気治るような力出てくれればいいのに
まあそうしたっても病気は病気になるしね
それはもう避けられない事実なんです
どんな宗教家が来てね
まあどんなお祈りしても
一時的に病気治すと言ったって
じゃあその人々は死ななかったんですかね
ある病気治って他の病気になっちゃうし
みんな死ぬし だからくだらないことなんです
単なる人間の欲望をあおいでるだけ
人間の欲望をあおるんではなくて
それを消すようにしなさいと
心の汚れを成長するんじゃ
それに水をかけるんじゃなくて
それ捨てるようにしなさいというのが道なんです
それ心にある汚れをとにかくもうあおいで成長してくれる
というふうにまあ ことになってますし
まあカルマが消えるのは一応悟った時はカルマは消える
で 我々の場合もカルマが消える時あります
で 一つの業をしたならば
その業の アビダンマなんですね
これはね これもアビダンマです
アビダンマから見れば 7分の1は今世で結果が出てくる
また 7分の1は来世で結果が出るんです
あの何か業をすると あの即業心というジャワナ心ってありますね
七つ これ即業心あのジャワナというんだけれども
あの そのジャワナの心は七つあるんで
この即業心七つは業なんですね
力持ってますから それ七回即業心が生まれて死んじゃう
だから一回目は弱い 二回目は一回の影響で強い
どんどん三四は結構五まで強い
それで六で弱くなって
七ですごく弱くなって即業心が終わっちゃうんですね
そこで一回目の即業心は今世で結果出す
七回目の即業心は次の世で結果を出す
二から六番目の六つの業がいつか結果を出す
貯まる だから貯まるのは二から六番目までの即業心です
だから仏教から言えば
一つの行為をしても 瞬間の行為したっても
そこに業が七つあるんです
一個だけじゃないんです
例えば動物一匹殺したと
じゃあ業は一個や じゃないんです
これは数えられないほど業があるんだけど
大目に見たっても七つやってるんです
業 だから七回結果を受けるんです
一回の業したら結果は七回
七倍になっちゃう 七回になるんです
七倍ではなくて もっとたくさんですけど
その七回の業で一回目の僧侶心の業は今世で結果出す
七番目は次の生で結果を出す
でもいつでもそれ不可能なんです
我々やってるいいことを全部今世で結果が出るかというと出ないんです
例えばいいことをしたっても妨害業働いているとなかなかもう機能しないんです
ですから このほとんどのこの一回目の業が消えちゃう
結果出せなくなる それにも阿呆識カルマというんです
消えるカルマです そこで二回
七番も同じなんですね
七番目の業も それもこの次の生まれだから確実に結果出すっていうことじゃないんで
ほとんど重い業か 慣れてる業か
あるいは一番最近死の間際にやった業か
どっちか結果出しますから
このやってることほとんどもう消えちゃう
ですから ほとんどの我々にはいつでもあるんです
この消える業が 厳密に言えば
ほとんどこの一番目と七番目は消えちゃうわけですね
だからこの今世で結果出せなかったら
このカルマのエネルギーは終わり
この心からそのエネルギーは消えちゃうんです